i speak to lots and lots and lots of
people i can't even tell you um famous
and whatever
but when i saw you guys i told my team
i'm speaking to these young brothers in
the us and this is what motivates me
this not the other stuff not the big cnn
and uh big
actors and actresses whatever it is all
the big stage stuff this is what
motivates me
you guys
because you're the next generation and
seeing the youth in the zeal the love
the care the passion that seems to be
lost in so many other places
you guys have got a you've got a battle
in front of you and allah pray equips
you physically morally uh emotionally
financially in every possible way to be
able to to take that on and to carry the
deen
in every nook of cranny in this in this
dunya because in the end that's
bad
[Music]
[Music]
podcast in the dunya the three muslims
podcast today we're joined with another
very special guest brother muraz
dear brothers and sir absolute pleasure
to be on here on your show
happy it's a pleasure to have you so for
those who don't know
about you your story who you are let's
just start with the a brief uh
introduction to who you are
yeah my name is uh marzen begg i'm a
resident and a citizen of the united
kingdom great britain born and raised
here my parents originally from pakistan
i am known mostly as a former guantanamo
prisoner who is the outreach director
for the advocacy group cage which
campaigns against war on terrorism
policies um
guantanamo was just three years of my
life
and there have been
decades before and after that and
there's much to discuss
around that but suffice to say um
that the past 20 years and we're just
approaching now 20 years since the uh
anniversary of the beginning of the
first prison of central guantanamo i
have been uh either a prisoner or
fighting against the concept of
imprisoning people primarily muslims
without charge or trial uh was something
that i endured um i saw people beaten to
death i saw people tortured i saw i
endured it myself
and alhamdulillah have been campaigning
for those people who have been in that
situation as i said since
i'll reward you for your work so just a
quick cycle for that campaign and the
work that you do if our viewers or
anyone in this video wants to support
that work how can they do so yeah please
go to
cage.ngo cage.ngo
there you will find all our campaign
work whether it's on guantanamo whether
it's on state level islamophobia whether
it's on various laws and legislations
that are being passed that uh that
affect the muslim community whether it's
here in the us france austria wherever
um we are challenging not just not just
state level law but also bringing out
the stories and the voices of the people
who have been uh subjected to those
violations of the laws
that is amazing
that is amazing so all the viewers you
can find the link in the description
inshaallah allah head over there
um do what you can support the work but
the news insha'allah so
brother [ __ ] let's start with your
story in particular how did this all
start was it just one day you found out
that uh you know
they were watching you or were you just
kind of like dragged out of your home
one day
uh no i mean i i i expected something
but but of course nobody expected what
happened after 9 11 maybe many of your
viewers are young may not even know the
detail about that so let me just go into
a bit of the background story
i was i think around the time um you
know in my late 20s mid to late 20s i'm
i'm
you know close to 54 now but this was
before 9 11 i had been working on a
project to build a school in afghanistan
at the time the taliban was in power
which is important because they're back
in power again but at the time they were
in power and they the demonization of
them had started but not really it
wasn't so bad and one of the things that
was said about them like they say no is
that they're not allowing female
education so
when i learned that some of the brothers
that i knew were helping to set up a
school in afghanistan for girls i wanted
to be part of that because i wanted to
break that stereotype and i know from
islamic history that as the prophet saws
that seeking knowledge is an obligation
on every muslim that means men and women
um so i knew this was very important so
i i got up i was left with my family my
wife my children and with a plan to go
and live in afghanistan talk for a while
to open this school to run it to be part
of it and to try to get the benefit from
it and at the same time live in an
islamic and a muslim society that was
quite different to here
when
of course the 9 11 attacks happened
which was about several months after i'd
arrived um things started to change but
slowly the invasion didn't start
immediately started several weeks after
and of course osama bin laden his
organization were based in afghanistan
but in the other part of the country
that was really connected to us
i was in the capital kabul
uh but then the u.s cruise missile
starter strikes started
um and they started to land in and
around the area
the capital and i saw them at night come
and land and smash into the ground it
looked like fireworks but with a massive
earth earth shaking shock ear splitting
um the windows of my house and all of
the houses on the same on the same road
smashed and cracked
and and
you knew that something was going to
happen and it started to happen and that
was just the introduction uh shortly
after that they started to drop bombs in
the daytime because the taliban didn't
have anti-aircraft capability to hit
american aircraft and so forth so they
started to bomb in the daytime and that
felt like earthquakes massive bombs 15
000 pound bombs that really shook
the earth beneath your feet even though
they were dropped miles away
so it was under this eventually me and
my wife and kids and evacuated
eventually got to pakistan after a very
long drawn-out difficult painful journey
um in which
people died people
were wounded people suffered all sorts
of injuries uh but allah we were safe
and eventually i made it to a house i
have relatives in pakistan that's where
my parents originated from
and on the night of the 31st of january
2002 now this is several months have
passed
um
i there was a knock on my door and i was
in my house in islamabad in the capital
pakistan i opened the door my wife and
kids sleeping inside
and there's a group of people standing
right in front of me no uniforms
no id badges
nothing
one of them puts a gun straight to my
head it pushes me
into the forecourt onto the floor in my
house in in the forecourt
they then jumped on top of me shackled
my hands behind my back shackled my legs
and just before they put a hood off my
head i saw them walking to the room
where my family is and i said please
don't go in there and that was it that's
the last time i saw i didn't even see my
wife that night i didn't see my kids
my kids were all young at the time but
young but old enough to remember old
enough to to make visualizations and
remember to this day and now that
they're all grown adults exactly what
happened
they carried me to the back of this
vehicle in the back of this vehicle so i
thought that's i thought thus far that
these are kind of bandits they've come
to to rob me they're coming to take my
money because i'm a westerner in
pakistan and you know poor countries
people do that
but then when i was lying in the back
two guys turned around and they looked
at me
and they were dressed like pakistanis
they were wearing you know afghani type
caps and shoulders
but they were white
they were you could see i could see the
faces of the guys that got some have
gone red from the from the heat
and they looked at me and spoke in
american accents and it was obvious
these guys are not pakistanis
and they said you can either answer our
questions here or in guantanamo and
guantanamo was already open by that time
and the shocking images of people in
orange jumpsuits kneeling blacked out
goggles and ear defenders and face masks
was already around the world so when
they said that i said i realized this is
very serious
and then one of them he gets this pair
of handcuffs
and he said you know who gave me these
handcuffs
and i'm lying in the back of the seat on
the
on
on in the prone position thinking i
really don't care who gave me these
handcuffs because i want to know how the
hell to get out of this situation and he
says
the wife
of one of the survivors of one of the
victims rather
of the september 11 attacks a police
officer himself
it's his wife that gave him the cuffs
and he said i've been sent to catch the
people who did it
and you're one of them
and i thought yeah
and i said it to matt that's straight i
said wouldn't she think you're stupid
for catching the wrong guy
and that was they drove me off to this
secret location
held there by the pakistanis for several
weeks and then
off into u.s
military custody at the pakistani air
base so he said this was just the
beginning this is just the starter
of being in us custody and it becomes
brutal it becomes more and more brutal
as we go along and i can tell you in
different aspects i just don't want to
keep talking without you saying
something um
but essentially my dear brothers and
sisters were watching
this was an odyssey it was a journey and
this journey was about to teach me
things about my life about my faith
about my connection to allah
that i had no idea
i had no idea i was capable of
um and inshallah will describe that too
as we go along
you shall allah do you want to jump in
quickly or
man i'm just i'm i'm not saying much
because i'm i'm listening more and i i
really want to you know really get into
the the meat of the issue and the
journey um but before we go on i had
some questions so your family at this
time i know you know at that time you
had no way of contacting them
communicating with them uh or you know
so on so forth so
what did you do when was the next time
that you ever got a hold of them was it
after all the years of being in prison
and finally coming back or was there any
way for you to get in touch with them in
the meantime
uh
that's a very good question spanner
first for anybody that is a father
anybody that is a parent these are the
most important things that you feel you
do feel but i'm going to tell you
something please do remind me there's
something even more important something
more important than your family okay
and i'll give you an example of that
but uh
at this point you do think where's my
family did they are they in custody
are they holding them i just don't know
uh so the for the first seven to eight
months i had no idea
absolutely no idea what happened to my
family um
but there is one thing
that i did do
which again this is from the qatar of
allah
when the police or the these
whoever they were i didn't know who they
were at the time they were the isi the
pakistani intelligence with the cia
i found that later when they took me to
this secret kind of location
first i put my hand on my pocket and
realized i got my phone so these guys
hadn't searched me and that what made me
believe even more that somehow these
really this really is not the police
police would search you right
um
the phone was still in my pocket
and there's still some charges like
about one one bar still left of the
battery so i picked up the phone and i
called two people i called my friend who
lived close to where my family was and i
said please go and check on them and say
that they're okay and which which he
said he would then the second person i
called was my father in in england in
the uk and i said i was whispering down
the phone dad i've been kidnapped i
actually said dad i've been kidnapped
and
he was shocked he didn't know what to do
and i said but there's americans here
i've been kidnapped by americans
i'm saying it like this
and
my dad had the sense of mind to to i
think that i learned later to to call
lawyers and to start and he began his
campaign from that moment from that
moment
um
but for me that's it the phone battery
died i didn't want these guys to know
that i've got a phone so i broke it up
and then when they took me to the toilet
there's no toilet myself um i just threw
it down the toilet
and
you know the other thing that happened
which i don't talk about much is i
actually did plan and escape and the
escape was
that on my window
there were
bars that had been screwed in it was it
was not a cell like the others this was
just like a room
and they put bars on the window
and i had a buckle on my belt that if i
pulled it out i could get the edge and
put it into the screws and i took out
every screw of every bar
and my plan was my plan in my mind was
to take the bars out in the middle of
the night when i knew the guards were
not
patrolling
for this very short period of time i've
worked it out after a couple of weeks
and then i would get out the window and
i would escape jump over the wall
there's a guard sitting with it with a
gun but i'd get over and then i'd run i
had no shoes on i'd run barefoot get
into a taxi get me driven somewhere run
off not pay the fare because i had no
money and
then i would try to get to somebody
somewhere
that was my plan in my mind but
strangely enough one day they took me
for interrogation brought me back
somebody came up looked at the window
saw the bus
saw something then they took me to a
different place where the windows were
totally sealed
and that was the escape plan all done
subhanallah now i know all of the
viewers are definitely you know very
keen on knowing what happened next in
your story but you did remind us to uh
you know tell you that there's something
more important than family so what would
that be
you know
it's hard it's hard to say this right
but i was just speaking to a friend of
mine shakarama who himself was in
guantanamo for 14 years i remember i was
only there for three but we were both
we're both very good friends and we
lived together in the same house in
afghanistan worked on the same projects
together he ended up in guantanamo for
14 years i was released for three years
i was a british citizen he was not
that's the difference um he's here and i
was with him just yesterday
and there's something an american
soldier he said to me you know it would
bring the soldier
was crying when he told me this the
soldier had tears in his eyes so he
asked me if i knew this guy
shaku i said yeah he's my friend and we
were in separate cells i never saw him
again i never saw him in guantanamo we
were just in cells he said you know that
guy's amazing he said
um
he said please can you bring me a
photograph because they don't they
didn't let him keep his photographs of
his family in his cell they were outside
in a box
so he said could you please just let me
see the photograph of my kids and his
kids were similar to my age very really
young and this has been after close to a
year and a half since he'd been in
custody
he showed him the pictures show the
soldier the picture there were a lot of
good decent soldiers i have to say
there's lots of good american soldiers
so he showed this soldier he said look
these kids these are my children this is
so so sad
etc one of his children was born after
he was in custody so he never saw that
kid until he was 15 years old first time
in his life
and
though his son and my son were born at
the same time but my son ayoob um i saw
him only when he was three years old so
you see the difference right so he looks
at this picture and he says you know
these kids are more beloved to me than
anything in my life
then what the what the soldier said next
is what what is to the soldier's eyes
he said but i have to tell you something
there's something even more beloved to
me than these children
and he said that is
me
calling you to the dean of allah
now this soldier was a blond-haired
blue-eyed big bolting muscles probably a
christian
and the soldier understood
the the power of his words and what he
meant the depth of what he meant
me calling you to the dean of islam is
more beloved to me than these children
who i love more than my life itself
and
the other part of this greater story
there are many soldiers in guantanamo
who took the shahada some in guantanamo
some outside black white hispanic male
female we can talk about that if this
time but it was important that i get
this out
to you guys because i don't often talk
about those details sometimes people
just want to hear about oh what happened
in the story but there's so many layers
so many parts of it and when i'm
speaking to young brothers like you i'd
like to get those parts out rather than
to just tell a story chronologically um
so yeah it was that that thing more
beloved than your most beloved children
um
that people people would give their
lives for
wow
this might be a side question but
i'm wondering when you when you do a lot
of these podcasts and interviews why why
do these nuances not come up most of the
time is it because people just want to
prioritize like what happened and and
that's what usually gets clicks and
views or what is it
it depends who you're speaking to right
so you know now i'm speaking to a lot of
media i've just been speaking to the bbc
today they don't care about that stuff
they stop but they don't get they don't
care about it at all right so it depends
who and that's why when i speak to guys
like you who i know you have a different
take on things and you're doing it for a
different reason um i find it important
to to bring these things out and it just
because there's so much over this period
of time like there's so much has
happened
and certain people like i'm looking at
your faces you're triggering those
responses within me right as i speak if
i was speaking to somebody else probably
i'd be talking about a different aspect
so this all has to do with the
reflection and um
so
in regards to this soldier you said that
that that car really touched him hearing
that from the brother really touched him
that soldier end up accepting islam i
don't know i don't know if he did but i
just remember that he's the one who told
me that soldier is the one that told me
the story right i wouldn't have
he's the one who told me see shakur is
my friend but shaky never told me that
story ever he's never told me that story
even since he's returned
but you see you learn things about other
people
sometimes about your closest friends
that you you never even hear from them
wow and i'll tell you another story now
that we're at it shaker once and this is
really you know when i heard this again
i started to cry because i was imagining
him i've not seen him since we lived
together i just heard he's in custody
and i was in interrogation and the
entire this was very brutal in kandahar
they stripped us naked they'd beaten us
they tortured us they just ripped off
our clothes they spat upon us they
brought dogs to salivate over us and
taking photographs of us and chaka he's
got beautiful long lovely hair and beard
and they shaved it all off like a sheep
and they did the same to me and to
everybody
and in this when i'm in an orange
jumpsuit and hands behind my back and a
soul just pushing me down shouting
screaming cursing
um in the middle of this
place that they built just by kandahar
airport it's freezing cold
and that you know
you hear the sound of the gun being
cocked
and it's right against your head and
against your back and
all of that
the attempt to terrify you now
a soldier
i'm on my knees here and a soldier says
to me hey you do you know shakira you
know shakarama
i said yeah he's my friend
he said
that guy was just in this in hit just in
here before you
and you know
i'd heard that he'd been taken to
custody but i didn't know
and he said you know that guy's
i don't know what to say about that guy
said why he said because he's here
kneeling
kneeling here
with his hands cuffed and his legs
cuffed
and and
you know we're standing here
interrogating everybody here
and he's
telling me about islam
he's telling me about becoming a muslim
he's telling me about what this religion
is about he's telling me how you've got
it all wrong that this faith isn't about
death and destruction it's about life
and preservation it's about um
worshiping and giving that duty of
worship the due rights to the one who
created you and you as an american you
understand that more than a lot of
people in europe so i don't want you to
get it wrong and sakura told me this i
asked him about it yesterday i said why
did you do this he said because i lived
in america before this happened and i
know this is what he says and it's
shocking to hear this i know american
people are not bad people generally
this is a guy who's been imprisoned and
tortured for 14 years he said but there
is a great deal of ignorance
and the antidote to ignorance is
knowledge
so for the first many years i tried to
even in the hardest of circumstances
say that i'm going to give them
knowledge
even though he was also the leader of
the protests and the hunger strikes in
guantanamo
he said for the first several years
just i'm going to give them that that's
it
and personally i'd rather speak to you
about these these things than just about
my my boring old story well it's not
boring for some people but you know this
happened and this happened
chronologically because these are the
gems really honestly
that get missed out and so
uh i'm glad that they're coming out in
charlotte now yeah subhanallah i uh i'm
currently in uh i was in a placement at
uh at a hospital for a couple months and
i used to go back and forth it's like a
one-hour drive right so it was like two
hours every single day and i remember
for a good moment in time when we were
arranging these uh this interview with
you i was just listening to a bunch of
podcasts that you were in and i've never
heard these stories because all of the
stories that i used to hear on those
commutes were like you know what
actually happened different accounts um
the lady that you mentioned uh that hit
you up on facebook she was a guantanamo
um i believe guard and she took her
shahadah
and these were the stories that we never
heard the ones you're talking about now
um so you know i'm all for it you know
ramy what about you yeah alhamdulillah
maybe this is your episode we keep it
completely unfiltered anything you want
to talk about this is your show and yes
so let me let me yeah let me you know
start talking about different things
is that you know one of the great the
amazing things so they took me off into
the secret location and held me there
and then for a while two three weeks
then they handed me over to to the
americans to their military you probably
heard the story about when i said uh how
i prayed in custody right so
uh yeah so all of that stuff happened in
the brutalization so let's move past all
of that
and now i'm held in in with all these
other prisoners now these prisoners are
from all over the muslim world and not
eve some not even from the muslim world
some from europe some uh chinese weakest
though that sorry that's wrong to say
that they are from the muslim world uh
it's the the china has has imposed
itself on their land and tried to force
them but there were weakers they were
people from the maldives islands people
from australia from
uh canada young boy um you might have
heard of him um he was 14 at the time
when they first supported him into
custody and i don't know if you know his
story but it is really one of the most
shocking and he was so this something
that you should know is that they were
lots of children stroke young adults
from 12 13 14 15 16 17 all of these ages
um
in u.s custody they were bought in uh
tortured
he was a canadian he is a canadian
citizen
he was held in guantanamo from the age
of 15
until he's 25
and eventually went to canada and the
canadian government compensated him and
the the prime minister trudeau
apologized to him but not after
this kid to describe to you what he'd
gone through they brought him in when i
was there in bagram so they moved me
then from a place called kandahar where
i was held in the first few weeks and to
a place called bagram bagram was
recently taken over by the taliban again
and
it's just shocking because
this was a place where so much abuse
happened
and this was probably for me one of the
worst places i was held there for one
year
and in that year
many things happened you know they i saw
two people murdered i saw one prisoner
kicked to death punched to death because
the prison the soldiers found it amusing
that every time they kicked him he said
allah allah
his name was delaware he was a taxi
driver his hands were tied to the top of
the cage right in front of myself and
they kicked him repeatedly like thai
boxing style kicks to the to to his
thigh uh and because they found it
amusing oh look every time this we're
kicking he says
kick him again let's kick him again kick
him again they kept on kicking him over
100 times until his leg
um the blood clotted
and uh it caused his heart to have a
heart attack and the autopsy report said
that if he'd survived he would required
amputation
so in this horrific place
you know there were
terrible things happening and they were
amazing thing happening
so we couldn't play praise salah in
jamaa you weren't allowed to do salah in
jamaa
right
we were in a cell where there's like
about 10 10 prisoners in each cell
we started to pray together
and then
you know may allah hold into account
this egyptian guy who's working for the
americans he says don't let these guys
pray in jama because when they the imam
when he's in front he's not really
reciting the quran he's talking to them
he's telling them things
so because of this and i have to
describe him i don't know what other way
to describe him is
uh would say such a thing
uh they stopped us praying and when we
would pray together they'd come and
storm into ourselves kick us in the
middle of sajdah put their boots on us
in the middle of the and i saw one
prisoner like
a soldier saying to him i'm your god
here you should be praying to me you
should be kneeling to me and so this was
like one of this
these times and moments where
these are the very things you hear about
in the history of islam
that
muslims were forced
to bow but they would bow to none but
allah
and the stories of ahmad and yasir in
the quran that even if those who did
their hearts were filled with iman
but nonetheless all of this so there
were prisoners from everywhere the whole
world all gathered in this
in this experiment center
and this is even before we got to
guantanamo
and
so
after having gone through all of this
i was actually looking forward to to to
go to guantanamo just imagine right as a
muslim and you guys know this and again
this is not something
that everybody would understand
but they give us one bottle one 500
milliliter bottle of water a day to
drink from
to drink that's the only water you got
you have no water for water
you have no water for also
you have no water for anything but to
drink you drink it and if you want to
use it for wudhu you've got nothing to
drink so you take your choice
so what do you do now in this situation
what do you do so imagine i'm in this
situation for one year
so i don't do
for one year
and so forth
it goes back to what we know from the
dean this deen was born in a desert
and if you don't find water then do dry
ablution
and it's done you know it's it's but you
got you got 0.5 liters a day just for
drinking
yeah that's it just for drinking
so all you do then is you learn in fact
i did taiyaman for so long that by the
time i got to guantanamo and there was
water in the cells
i actually forgot the the kind of the
sequence of
i forgot it for a while i couldn't
remember do i do the the mouth first or
the nose or the nose because that none
of that features
so all of these basic things
uh ramadan comes it goes you don't know
you don't know what
you know allah tells you um
you know that you fast from sun rise
just before sunrise to sunset what if
you don't know when the sunrise what if
you don't know when the sunset what if
you don't know the weather what if you
don't know the prayer times what if you
can't see outside you don't know when it
you don't know whether it's light or
dark what if you have no food to open
your fast
what if they bring you your food four
hours or five hours after the first
what do you do and despite all of these
conditions we fasted
we tried to pray
and the best day for me despite all of
that we used to get punished for
reciting the quran aloud
when i say punished
if they hear you talking loud or saying
anything loud they take you to the front
of the cell they tie your hands above
the cage like that suspended above your
head and you're on your toes and you're
there left for hours sometimes days
that's for reciting the quran
despite that and one of my most blessed
times for me was that iris i memorized
subtle bakara in that situation
and for me it was a big thing it was a
big thing because before that i'd only
memorize parts of the last juice
so you know again i have to say to you
that these places are testing they may
be testing ground for the american
military to see how they can break us
but it's also a testing ground for allah
to see
to see who is patient from amongst you
who will stand the test who will
remember who he is who will remember and
that we are we are our deen is the in we
inherit
the story the lives the traditions the
struggles of the prophets and not a
single prophet came that wasn't tested
with his team you know
i'm completely speechless
as as a muslim who who grew up in the
west lived in the west and sees the the
problems that muslims face nowadays
in the west they're like they're
literally nothing subhanallah and to
hear stories like this
it's so shocking like all i can think
about is the sahaba radhila
i can only think about like
that struggled for the sake of islam and
hearing what was the name of the brother
that you you told the story
so the the young brother his name is
he's from canada when also i forgot to
mention when they first brought him into
custody right
he had lost his eye
he's 14 just turned 15.
uh they had a gunshot wound
right from his chest like just above his
chest i don't know how survived you do
search on his name and you look a
picture of his it looks like he's dead
so they got him from this compound in
afghanistan which they'd blown up
totally
everybody was killed
except for him
and just to try to finish him off
somebody fired a shotgun uh
like point blank and literally he had an
exit wound here and
you know to this day he's damaged but if
you look at him and you hear him and you
see interviews with him i just did a
talk with him yesterday his smile is
infectious the way he speaks his iman
his his uh
his mannerism of how he speaks
he is absolutely blows people away
really literally from his um
he became a man he never went to school
in other than guantanamo guantanamo was
the only school he ever went to
um
and
i mean yeah he did go to school prior to
that but after guantanamo that's it he
grew into amanda you see the pictures of
him as a boy and then you see him as a
man and you think all of that happened
to him while he's held and this abusive
situation
and the really amazing thing was that
the older brothers all became like
father figures to him and nobody in
guantanamo remains in one place they
keep moving around from cell to place to
cell to place so even the close
relationships you build with people they
only last a few months and then after
that it's just gone
i um going to say that uh it's in these
times that a lot of the times when you
recall back to the events that took
place you only remember the highs and
lows at times um everything else kind of
just fades away so what were some of the
more memorable things um if we fast
forward now to guantanamo sure yes so i
mean after a year of being in this place
as i said i was i'm sent to guantanamo
and most of the time in guantanamo they
put me in solitary confinement so only
for a short period of time at the end
i'm with other prisoners but here i'm in
a in a room
and in that room that room is like uh
there's a cell the cell is made of metal
it's made of kind of uh
metal mesh like that so you can see
through but it's gonna be like that um
and there's a a soldier or soldiers
watching you 24 7. i mean even when you
go to the bathroom i come up a lot i
mean like
all the time
uh so what we would do is just put up
like a little sheet halfway through and
we use the bathroom and whatever but it
is of course it's humiliating there's no
doubt about that
um but we have to remember again go back
to the stories of our prophets and the
sahaba and understand that they were
humiliated and they were they attempted
to disgrace them
but all that happened happens
and the reliance of allah increased for
me uh i'd say there's several different
things memorable i have to say um
there's so many there's so many things
that come to mind but one of them is
just a simple thing in guantanamo
there's lots of animals
uh some you see some you don't as a
prisoner but they exist as tarantulas
snakes
um
giant moths that big
um
and one day there's loads of crabs so
this crab walked into myself right and
it's my immediate reaction was oh my god
from the
side of my i think that's a tarantula or
something
so my immediate reaction is to get a cup
and to throw water at this crab it was a
crap it turned out to be a crab not a
friendship
and but it's quite big
and
it started to instead of doing what i
wanted it to do which is to get away it
started to scoop up the water and drink
it
and i thought subhanallah look at that i
i see something as a weapon
and this crack this this creature sees
it as a gift from allah
and think about this brothers like think
about this carefully there's a process
used on many not only it wasn't used on
me but it's been used on many prisoners
and it's called waterboarding
waterboarding is a technique of torture
that was
first used against muslims and jews in
spain
when they
sort of took back over and the
christians took back over spain
they started to
use this as a way to find out who's
still a muslim because islam had been
destroyed there now by the 1500s but
they were still trying to uh uh
investigate to see who's the who's who's
a secret muslim so one technique they
would have to see is the guy's
light open at project time or they go
and ask the kids you know does your
father bow down does he say allah
one of the techniques was that and they
would do this mostly to women is they
would tie them down onto like a bench
tie their hands tie their legs tie their
head
and pour water over their eye to their
noses and their mouth so that they feel
coming constantly like gallons and
gallons
and make sure that the mouth is
continued gets filled with water so you
feel like you're drowning
this in spanish was called tortura del
agua the torture of the water this was a
technique used against many of the
prisoners it was uh sanctioned or
allowed by
the legal authorities in the united
states of america against
uh several prisoners
and eventually when obama came into
power he admitted that we were torturing
people
uh japanese soldiers who water-boarded
american gis in world war ii were
prosecuted and convicted for war crimes
and then executed that's how serious it
is
um
but this waterboarding technique
was one of the numerous techniques
uh used against many of the prisoners
and as i said if you go back to its
history it's actually connected to
to to muslims
and the other thing i'd like to you know
so i want you to kind of think about
again because i'm talking to people in
the united states is that
you know if you read the history of
slavery
uh
and i don't know the story of alex
haley's roots or whatever it is you know
some people say it's not it's fiction
but
we know that
a significant number of the prisoners
that were taken from west africa
to america
were muslims
and they were taken by force
and they were taken in chains and they
were taken across the atlantic and they
were taken to america that's what
happened to us
the majority of us were all muslims were
taken in chains
and we were taken to the americas a
place we've never been before and the
majority of the prisoners you would
describe as black
maybe not
you know
african black but even then there was
many prisoners they took from
uh
from africa and from asia and so forth
so there's something kind of in the
history and so in terms of when we used
to converse with a lot of the black
soldiers
and tell them this
they would feel very uncomfortable very
very uncomfortable
and explain to them how can you partake
in something
that you know is the result of you
coming to this place and being forced in
fact many of you would find that you
originally
you were probably muslims
many who were originally prone and to
make you contend with this thing
right now here in front of you
that you're watching our abuse that
you're partaking in our abilities you
are a part of our abuse
so
as i said somewhat very uncomfortable
but as a result of that some of them
became muslims some of them left the
military some of them started to speak
out against guantanamo
um and some of them
said it's just my job
uh and others actually were happy to
partake in the abuse
and just as you know you can watch
uh was it django unchained unchained
yeah django unchained watch that and
you'll know there's there's one side and
there's another side let's just put it
that way there are people who are happy
to be part of that
and understand that uh
you know
i've now been assimilated
but those whose hearts were open
you know i have to tell you some of
those american soldiers they were
lifeline very very decent very good
people people have been bringing little
bits of chocolate
little bits of news
sometimes a piece of fish that they'd
caught in in the ocean
little acts of humanity
and because of that i have to tell you
and majority of the prisoners would say
this we don't hate america
that's the one reason because of those
decent soldiers
and whatever america may have done to us
they didn't do to us what they did
to or what china is doing to the uyghurs
and that is forcing them to convert
forcing them to renounce their faith
forcing them to drink alcohol forcing
them to eat pork
um the uyghur brothers who are with us
they say alhamdulillah that we weren't
sent to china and that we were sent to
america even though
both were abusive
that i think that is absolutely shocking
to hear subhanallah
that people
uh muslims were actually grateful to be
sent to
like wow
guantanamo bay
just wow that's
crazy
may allah so before we get back to the
uh the the more memorable parts and the
iman boosters and all of that i want to
ask a question so you said you don't
hate america or what do you say you
don't hate america americans what's your
view on the american government because
they seem highly hypocritical
yeah i mean when i say i don't i don't
hate
i don't i don't come out hating all of
america
uh i know american history very very
well one of my one of the biggest
influences in my life is malcolm x
you know so
i i say that i am not a
i'm a victim of america like he says i'm
literally a victim of america
and uh if you see a poem i've written in
custody it's called indictment usa it's
a 52 verse rhyming point of the united
states of america what it's done how it
was born out of um what it did to native
americans what it did to uh black people
what it's done around the world so i'm
under no illusion about what america has
done or what it's capable of so when i
speak about american release about
it's about the experiences of those who
are decent people
whether it's the advocates whether it's
soldiers or whether it's other americans
that i meet uh who i know and again as i
said shakur himself he lived in america
and said this was not the america that i
knew that i'd experienced so it was
based on that ignorance that had become
like this but when america just to give
you an idea right i'll give you an
example
i was there when america
invaded and attacked afghanistan and
thousands died and they didn't give a
damn about the numbers right
the taliban maybe you agree with them
disagree with them it doesn't really
matter when the taliban took over
afghanistan not a shot was fired in
kabul
they didn't fire a shot so you have to
ask yourself one question
who should you follow
america or the taliban when it comes to
this particular issue the prophet
salallahu
it was bloodless
um
jerusalem it was bloodless
when the crusaders captured
jerusalem
the the the streets
ran
knee-high in blood
of not just muslims but of jews of
animals even
so the important part that we understand
this is that i am under no illusion
america
is
the most violent country in the history
of mankind
there is no more violent country than
america not even the mongols
and i say this because the mongols
killed people over hundreds of years
america can do that in that number in
one day and it has done
hiroshima vietnam korea afghanistan iraq
etc etc
but i still try to look at to see
that amongst americans there are people
who are deeply ashamed
deeply ashamed of its history and are
trying to kind of write that wrong
but like i said um
my
my refusal to give in to hatred because
hatred what it does it just eats you
from inside right yeah but it doesn't
mean i'm i'm i'm unaware
i'm very aware and in fact
probably more politically aware now than
i've ever been
about america and indeed britain because
britain is the let's say the great
grandfather of america
and britain's role in
uh colonization destruction of
indigenous peoples around the world not
just muslims but indigenous people
around the world the
intrinsic racism that exists within them
uh i'm a subjective to myself i've seen
it firsthand i've fought neo-nazis on
the streets in britain who carry british
flags and then they come along and say
to me if you're british you need to give
your loyalty to us
and they're seeking my loyalty while
they've got a gun put to my head
my loyalty isn't to your flag my loyalty
is to my experience of this country that
is good
not to your flag
it's a beautiful answer it's very
beautiful answers for allah and it's
very important that the muslims and just
frankly everyone they understand the
history of how we got here
now especially when you play into
the intricacies of what america is doing
in other places and what america
believes to be true and what they
proclaim because a lot of the time they
will proclaim that they go into these
countries they do these atrocities in
the name of of freedom and liberation of
these people but people don't actually
know the truth behind it
so they see you know one of the things
that people need to understand america
itself was born out of rebellion america
was it was a colony of britain and it
rebelled and as far as britain was
concerned everybody of
all all of the colonists uh were
terrorists george washington and his
entire movement were terrorists britain
burnt down the white house twice british
soldiers wanted that twice in its
history so
we can't pretend like
politics is not important and the
one person's on man's freedom fighter is
another man's terrorist that's happened
throughout history um
there's a time when ronald reagan you
know president of the united states
america described the mujahideen of
afghanistan including eunice khalis who
gave his bail his pledge to the taliban
off in 2006 um
he said that these guys are like our
finding fathers they are brave warriors
because they were fighting against the
soviet union so yesterday's mujahid is
today's terrorists so
we should be very clear is that you will
not determine
who i
uh uh deemed to be a freedom fighter or
not you will not do that through your
politics and we'll see through it and
point it out
yeah yeah
it's beautiful that that truly is
beautiful so
i'm trying to go i guess back and forth
between the more like political stuff
and the more like beautiful
so
let's hear some more some more beautiful
stories that come up
um okay so there's one really lovely one
it's again it happens in guantanamo red
it's still happening and that is
precisely at maghrib time at maghrib
time what do we do
we hear the advantage or somebody calls
the other
and we prepare for prayer right and
that's no different than guantanamo
guantanamo brothers are in blocks
different blocks so some blocks
uh are close to one another and they can
hear uh others they can't so each place
will call its owner then and there'll be
a more of them in each different part
and it's beautiful because the mind then
could be from chad could be
it could be from mauritania pakistan
a chinese week it doesn't really matter
but it could and the imam will be based
upon where he is in proximity in his
cell because you can't move cells so the
imam could be a young kid or it could be
an old man from afghanistan it's just
there's a beauty about that
but at that time
at the same time and they're not doing
it
the us military does this anyway at
sunset they call it i think the taps um
they play
the us national anthem
and it's played on giant loudspeakers
along around the island right and
there's a huge flag
uh
in the middle of the island and the
soldiers are required by military
protocol to wherever the wherever they
are they must face the flag and raise
their hand and salute the flag
so one of the prisoners is an australian
prison he said look at this i remember
the days that he was just so he said
look
two groups of people
both saluting the object of their
devotion one group the one group
interesting military does that
the other group does faces the east and
does that allah
and then he said i wonder
which of those two groups is the most
sincere
right
which one is doing it because he's doing
it out of his heart
and which one is doing it because he has
to and he thinks it's a stupid thing
and it's obvious it was obvious because
a lot of the soldiers wouldn't do it
they said i ain't doing that forget that
nobody's watching i ain't doing it right
but
if nobody's watching it i ain't doing it
the muslim what is the allah
is that you worship allah
as if you see him knowing that you can't
see him but he sees you
you know you
you you don't know
um who's watching and who's not watching
but you know allah is watching
and so you see again there's a contrast
a spiritual contrast between one group
and then and the other
and and uh
you know it was these little things
somebody just picks it up the guy who
said it was a revert he didn't know much
about islam at all just being picked up
and caught in the middle of afghanistan
but he just picked up this thing and i
thought wow look at how powerful that is
subhanallah
that being said um
uh today you know these were all nice
stories and all but i have i have more
of a serious question and i don't want
to you know completely go 180 but
uh we live in a society today where you
know people hear all your problems they
they understand that the things that
they deem as problems are not really
problematic at all whatsoever right um
people have become soft today in terms
of coping and dealing with uh you know
the daily struggles of their lives so
what is your advice for our brothers and
sisters watching to really toughen up
mentally not everyone can go through
exactly what you went through and you
know may allah protect us from that and
may allah bless you for enduring all the
trials and tribulations that you've gone
through um and all those similar to you
i mean but what can people do and
particularly when you got out
how did you deal with the ptsd
the daily anxiety the mental troubles
and all that
you know there's this this is um
the prophet sallam taught us that if we
see a people afflicted by something that
we should say alhamdulillah we should
praise allah that you weren't afflicted
by that
so you know you see something that
happens to people there's still people
there's still 39 brothers in guantanamo
and so i praise allah that i'm not one
of them
i praise the lord that i'm not one of
them because
that's it any any joy i had left in life
i would never have had it from my family
at least there'd be a different type of
joy there's another kind of joy but it's
very it's it costs too much
and i'm not going to say nobody can take
it everybody can take it because the
difference between us and and those who
say don't believe is allah says like you
can live for allah
that allah doesn't test the soul with
more than now you don't know
what that is until you've been tested
and it can i as i said i know brothers
have been in prison for 15 16 17 years
i've met prisoners because of the work i
do with cage i've met people who've been
in prison for 21 22 23 years
and seen them to come out to lead
revolutions against the very people who
had them in prison
like lead the revolution uh so you just
don't know
that the soul doesn't know what will
transpire tomorrow you just don't know
what you have to do is have your
reliance on allah that's what the most
important thing
learn what it is to have tawakkal learn
what it is to
put
if
tie your camel do whatever is your
humanly possible but ultimately allah is
the one who's going to decide your fate
and have
pure
trust
that feel good have only good thoughts
about allah and trust him
and even if you lose something in this
dunya allah has told you so many times
again and again and again that you will
be rewarded manifold
and we all know in the end you know what
it is about what have we prepared for
for death i've seen so many people die
in my life
some in literally in a battlefield some
by bombs some by natural death some by
an accident a bedridden buried my young
sister who's six years old
who's two years old my mother when i was
six years old um one after the other
death is a
and i say this not to say there's
anything especially about me you go to
the muslim world or even the the
developing world people dying all the
time
and you'll find poor people generally
though not always
always have a connection to something
because they know how trials and
tribulations start from the day we're
born and they don't enter it to wheat
till we end so they're connected to them
and we live a life of luxury
a life of instant gratification a life
of whenever we want something we get it
straight like that if it's not there
within the next day or the next hour
we're complaining
um and we lost sabar with lost special
and i include this in myself in the west
you go to a muslim country where none of
those things you take for granted and
automatically you have to step back a
few years few decades
in cases
and it makes you reliant on on allah
rather than
the arrogance of humankind in which that
we think we can have every single thing
without a cost um
so really my brothers and you know
that's what i would say and sisters who
are watching is that
the reliance on allah needs to come back
and we need to build our strength and
that will make strong believers
and and
we need that strength because tests
ahead are coming that will be greater
than guantanamo
the entire thing is made me very
specious to be completely honest um
subhanallah um and just to add on to the
point allah
there there's a hadith i don't know if
it's hadith
but it says that
jannah is filled with hardships and
trials and that jahannam is veiled with
desires
so
literally if you're living a life of
pure comfort and pure contentment and
not contentment in the sense that you
can come with allah but pure comfort in
contempt in the sense that oh you know i
want pizza i'll order pizza i'll be here
in 30 minutes you know or something like
that and you're not concerned with allah
and allah is not testing you
you have to question where your
destination is going to be because
it tells you that hell is veiled with
desires and in in this kind of comfort
but jannah is veiled with that hardship
the hardship that brother moaza
mentioned that the the prophets endured
that this habendar that the righteous
and the sabbath and the forerunners had
to render subhanallah yeah and that's
exactly that's exactly true that you
know you know a beautiful simple
beautiful hadith connected to what we're
talking about
that this prison this life this life is
a prison for the believer
he's he's imprisoned and he wants to be
able to prepare for the greater life and
it is a garden of paradise
for the disbeliever so everything that
this believer seeks it's all in this
dunya and he wants everything here and
now
and when that's over his life is over
and our life is yet is just about to
start
subhanallah it's so beautiful even one
of my students the other day they
messaged me asking this question
how do you respond to a person who says
that all the non-muslims have such a
great life and muslims are suffering
i'm like well what do you define a good
life as that what they have money they
have that fortune they have whatever for
80 years and then and then they die do
you think that stuff brings them
contentment do you think there aren't
these people that that actually hate
their lives or themselves or they can't
sleep at night and you have the muslims
who have very little but they they have
that walk they have their islam and
because of that their life is beautiful
so let me tell you something that you
brought that up and that's a really
important thing so there is a numerous
soldiers
numerous american soldiers
let alone those who served in iraq and
afghanistan but those who served in
guantanamo i kid you not
many of the soldiers had to go to
something called combat stress
right
we're in the cages we're tortured we're
about away from our families but the
soldier is required to go to combat
stress
that they you know when somebody does
upon themselves and it hurts them
you know they oppress themselves allah
says we didn't oppress them they pressed
themselves how do you press yourself by
taking part in something that your soul
knows you're doing wrong that you're
torturing people you're abusing them
you're keeping away them from your from
their families they did nothing to you
you have no proof against them you don't
even know what they're supposed to have
done to you and you brought them to this
place now you the soldier who signed up
you're supposed to be an inheritor of
the brave warriors defending america and
all of that stuff that's supposed to be
true about you
you're in the gym all the time and then
here you are
you've got men who are a hundred years
old who've got hearing aids that you
take the hearing away away from him
because you say this could be used as a
weapon you've got people double amputees
who lost their legs these are brave men
who fought the soviets at a time when
america supported the mujahideen this
guy's left both his lost both his legs
on a landmine against the soviets and he
doesn't complain but you take his legs
away because you say he could use the
there's a stick to
beat somebody with you've got children
here 12 13 14 years old and you've got
others who have married men with kids
and you're threatening them with
children with pictures of their children
and you're doing all this to them you
think this is not going to go back and
haunt you
that's good so several american soldiers
committed suicide including some who
were in guantanamo at the time others
afterwards some went on to become uh
domestic abusers some went on to
harm themselves the american female
soldier i told you told me she took a
shirt and what what a story she told me
she said that and i know this is that
abuse against females in in the military
is so rife it's so common it's rape
is is we know this as soldiers because
some of the females used to come to seek
solace in us
because they wouldn't trust
um the others we when we look at the
soldier we could keep down because we
keep your eyes down and don't try to
ogle this you know that's that's what
islam teaches us the bible teaches that
but they know people don't care about
the bible or anything else
and so when they talk to us
one of the reasons why this sister was
she said you know what i i was turned to
to different things i tend to boys i
turned to alcohol i turned to
drugs everything except faith but you
guys turned to you guys abandoned
everything except faith
and
so
you know when people
are involved in that kind of abuse
there's one guy he called me he was an
interrogator for that same young boy
that i spoke of when i spoke to him
i swear by allah he was crying on the
phone
because he'd now joined the veterans
against the war movement
and he was speaking against what he'd
done himself
and he was crying
because he was his nickname was the king
of torture
that's by his own colleagues
so we come alhamdulillah iman raised
believe strong yes we've suffered
but we're not gonna my
heart is clean
the prisoner's heart is clean these guys
hearts are blackened
and and
subscribe
unfortunately and i say this
gravely unfortunately coming up in an
hour and we're going to have to end but
i pray to allah that allah allows us to
do this many times over and allah allows
us to become a series in which we speak
the truth or more so you inform us about
the truth so that we can spread it to
the youth insha allah so that the
upcoming generations can look to stop
these abominations and truly make a good
change in sha allah i mean
it's absolute pleasure for me to really
to speak in this way and not to speak in
in the ways that i speak in a lot of
places except there aren't that many
places that we can do this properly as
muslims and and feel confident enough
and to bring out that those aspects of
our theme that are so important that
kept us alive that keep that that are
the purpose of our life um so any place
where that can be done inshallah i'll be
more than happy to do that and actually
even try to bring some brothers who
would never speak to the media
but they'll speak to you guys because
and i'm talking about brothers like i
mentioned 14 15 years make me look like
a child in my experience so hopefully
inshallah bring some of those guys to
you
i have one last question for you um it's
kind of like a two-part question but uh
after all the years of your life that
you've lived all the wisdom that you've
required um what is number one your
favorite hadith or at least one of
number two your favorite ayah from the
quran
well let me figure some first begin with
my favorite ayah though there are many
impossible but
amongst those are those who have gone
off and are now shaheed and there are
those who are still waiting and they
didn't change one iota
and perhaps my favorite hadith is a very
short hadith
kun fit
and with that being said uh is there
anything else uh that's on your mind or
any question for us no i just you're
like you know i i i
when you guys contacted me
uh as i said i speak to lots and lots
and lots of people i can't even tell you
um famous and whatever but when i saw
you guys i told my team i'm speaking to
these young brothers in the us
and this is what motivates me
this not the other stuff not the big cnn
and uh big actors and actresses whatever
it is all the big stage stuff
this is what motivates me
you guys
because you're the next generation and
seeing the youth in the zeal the love
the care the passion that seems to be
lost in so many other places
you guys have got a you've got a battle
in front of you and allah pray equips
you physically morally uh emotionally
financially in every possible way to be
able to to take that on and to carry the
dean
in every nook of cranny in this in this
dunya because in the end that's
i mean
i mean
subscribe please
and subscribe the cause insha allah look
forward to many more episodes speaking
about this very very important topic and
topics related to it and with that being
said if there's no final words from the
the quran here
allah
[Music]
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zordsis we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you